on the dish this morning world-renowned
vegan chef Matthew Kenny he grew up on
the rugged coast of Maine and developed
a love of the great outdoors as well as
nature's bounty after culinary school
and an award-winning career in the New
York restaurant world he shifted his
focus and became a pioneer in the
plant-based food movement Kenny now
operates seven vegan restaurants around
the world including plant food and wine
in Los Angeles and Miami and double-0
here in New York where he brings a
healthy perspective to one of the
world's most popular foods Pizza Chef
Matthew Kenny welcome good morning thank
you for your pleasure tell us about this
table so we have a few dishes from our
various restaurants that's a yuzu
guacamole um from our new restaurant
plant house in Miami Beach roasted
cauliflower with green harissa and
pomegranate we have a few pizzas from
double-0 from our wood oven yeah um a
classic margarita with cashew mozzarella
that's a Faro sausage and this is a
sunflower basil pesto all right these
are tree nut cheese's so fermented
cashew with probiotic and a lot of
different condiments this is a
plant-based apple pie that we created
for our Thanksgiving dinner in Los
Angeles at plant food and wine out there
so it's an array of our and and we have
vegan cocktails which are just regular
cocktails tequila tequila is puppies I'm
sure this vegan thing might work out for
both of us I'm food and wine yeah what
we did not start out as a vegan chef
right
I started out hunting when I was a child
last a-main and I was a classically
trained chef so the first thing I
learned how to do was filet and butcher
and and cook everything from dr. lamb
you name it what was the turning point
it was a long process listening to my
body I was very much into yoga health
and wellness I love food and dining in
wine but I also love optimal health and
I thought the two could come together
you know making healthy food really
exciting and colorful and bold so I just
took the plunge about 13 years ago and
changed my entire direction even before
that Matthew you were you were actually
working at Christie's and studying law
and so what what turned you to food then
well I moved to New York planning to go
to law school after college worked at
Christie's and I would go on my lunch
breaks everybody else would go to a cafe
and have lunch I would walk around
looking at restaurants reading menus
that was just addicted to
yeah something about restaurants was
calling me and I just loved the idea a
platform where you can be so creative on
creating design the atmosphere music
food and it just was a way to be social
and a little bit of an introvert it was
a way to be very social without being
fully exposed so I I just loved the idea
of it
and when you did get into the restaurant
world you trained in some very
prestigious institutions you yourself
have opened up a raw food Culinary
Institute tell us about how that came
about we opened the first state
accredited culinary school in 2009 and
now we have schools permanent or
temporary in New York LA Miami
Sydney's Paris Stockholm London Wow
Berlin coming Tokyo so we're doing
schools all over the world and online
we've had several thousand students
graduate we're trying to teach them how
to to do exactly what we do which is
create healthy food that actually tastes
good and will help people eat better
more and more chefs are embracing
vegetarian menus do you think dining
attitudes have changed dramatically I
mean if you look in even in New York for
example which may be a little behind LA
in terms of people embracing plant-based
jean-georges Vongerichten just too open
I know he's been on show he just opened
ABC V which is a vegetarian is no stop
by there after this and and you know
it's it's packed and all the new healthy
places are packed and I think it's
changing very quickly I think it's a
major tipping point happening where
plant centric will be the norm not you
know something that's just once once in
a while what about the business of it in
terms of sourcing the the vegetables and
the fruits and the necessary ingredients
is that landscape changed it has there
are products on the market now that
weren't even on the market five or six
years ago and I started Planet base 12
or 13 years ago you couldn't even find
rock cow beans and you know now they're
everywhere even probably Publix in Miami
so products are there farmers markets
are proliferating everywhere people are
more aware of organic and local and
sustainable it all starts with the
product that's the most important you
have seven restaurants now you're
opening to more we're opening in London
and we're opening another one in
California at four in California la New
York how's it consumer different in
London New York or
California uh you know California so
health friendly but New York double zero
we went with pizza instead of you know
more raw high-end food because we
thought you know New York it needs an
all year-round place it's worked really
well double zero has been pulled since
we open
Miami's been an incredible market for us
people are really embracing it we didn't
expect that because it was so such a
culture of enjoying meat and Anisa yeah
but it's really been like our one of our
best markets those beach bods vegan food
is good for that right um
as I asked you to sign the dish as we
customarily do on the show I will ask
you to answer the question we always
pose which is if you could share this
meal with anyone past or present who
would you share it with chef it would be
my parents I want to always give them as
much healthy food as possible so that's
a very sweet thing to do as a son as a
delicious thing to do Chef Matthew Kenny
thank you and for more on Matthew Kenny
and the dish head to our website at CBS
this morning dot-com